Oh my god guys look at this. Look at this place. What a pretty pretty place. It's gorgeous. It's nice here right? I mean it's seriously nice here. It's a seriously great spot. I mean like are you guys serious?
Dude I want you to be serious with me right now. Be serious right now. Okay guess what? We are serious. Yeah. Oh I hear now. Guess what? We are serious. Yeah. Oh, I hear what you're saying. We are SeriousXM. Welcome, listener, to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. J.B., are you, sorry, I know you're tired, but are you having like issues, like connection issues or something? Oh, I could be. You're a little glitched. Yeah, I might need a new computer. Yeah, all my ports and holes are rusty. You might want to get another take on that. If you...
You know what I mean? Let's put it a different way. After I finish at the computer store, go to the doctor. Or bring your computer to the doctor. So I apologize if I sound like a broken computer today, America. You don't need to apologize ever for anything. We love you. Yes, love. A lot.
You're very loved. Thanks, but I'm glitched out today. Okay, so, and don't worry about it. So anyway, I had, I just woke up a little bit ago, I had the craziest dream, I'm not making this up. I had a dream that was on. Was I in it? No.
I don't wanna hear it. Okay, great. Yeah, you know, I actually, don't you love it? Isn't the narcissism and you just flare up when someone says, hey, I had a dream about you last night. I stop everything. I go, oh yeah? Shawn, was I in it?
No, neither of you were in it. I was on the operating table and they took my heart out and I saw them taking all of it out. And the guy's like. Was it filled with jujubes? No, no. And the guy said, I said, okay, so some procedures, and I'm like, don't I need my heart to live all the blood?
I can't live too long with it outside of my body, right? He's like, no, you'll be fine. And then he started giving me fried chicken. Swear to God. He started putting a breast of fried chicken in your chest? No, but making me eat it with it. He's like, you want some of my lunch? I was like, okay, I was fried chicken.
Isn't that weird? What'd you have for dinner? I don't remember. What did I have for dinner? Really? Oh, I had pita bread with chicken and hummus. It's called a falafel? Yeah, that's it. Brrrr.
Pft. Boy, this is bad today. Yeah, it is. Should we just get through our guys? Let's start over. Let's start over. Everyone back to one. Okay.
Will, you forgot a couple of buttons at the top of your shirt real quick before we continue. It's real steamy out here right now. Is it? You look like George Hamilton. It's weird. Period. Period.
I get period George Hamilton? Yeah. Like from what era? All right, great. Ready, here we go. Everybody's real tired today. I know, wait, wait, Sean, wait, JB, wait. I just woke up.
Did you? I really did, just like, did you have a dream? All right. Ha ha ha ha. Did you, Seanny, did you wake up usual, like wake up at four, awake till seven? I woke up, yeah, I woke up at four, started playing games and reading stuff,
and then I went back to bed pretty quickly. What was the game? Don't say games with an S on it, it's Candy Crush, period, isn't it? No, no, I usually play like Hearts, or I'll play Solitaire, or I'll play something mindless so it kind of gets me sleepy again. Oh, because Candy Crush is the real brain teaser.
Yeah. You don't want to start the critical functioning at 4.30. A real brain teaser. I gotta get the yellows to match the bright reds. This is gonna keep you up. Exactly. All right, here we go. You guys, nobody's in the mood for us today,
but we're in the mood for our guests, so excited. Let's talk, he's too cool for school, guys. These are all your hints. I'd give anything for just a fraction of this man's brilliant acting and improv skills. Is he a mathematician? No, his first and last names start with the same letter. He's tall AF.
Soupy sales. That's what the kid's saying, no. He played Daddy Warbucks in Annie when he was 12. Like myself, a born and raised Midwestern boy, and also like myself, afraid of the ocean, he may or may not have juicy dirt on Jon Favreau. It's my new best friend, the always hilarious Vince Vaughn. Cut the shit.
Cut the shit. What's happening? Oh, cut. How are you guys? Cut the shit. What's happening? Cut the shit. How are you guys? Cut the shit. Good to see you guys. Cut the motherfucking shit. Now I'm up.
Now I'm up. Now I'm up too. Vince. Good morning. I like the steamy. The steamy's excellent. It's confident in the morning, Will, and I like that.
And the necklace, that draws my eyes as well. Dreams are important. I don't know what fried chicken in a dream means, but I like that. And a necklace that draws my eyes as well. Dreams are important. I don't know what fried chicken in a dream means, but I think it's something that you might want to look under the hood. And Bateman, I love that you are still figuring out how to record, because I'm the same way. I can't turn on a streamer without my 13-year-old daughter
helping me. Well, hold on. I feel this is like an old family member that I haven't seen for how many years, Vince? It feels like 10 years. It's been a while. It's great to see you. You too, pal. How's Kyla?
Kyla's doing great. Yeah, she's doing great. Kyla's your wife for my sister Tracy, who doesn't know that? Who is a registered broker? Yes, Tracy. Kyla's a woman that I've asked to... I took her hand. Canadian gal.
Canadian. Oh, yeah. I went north of the border on that, you know what it's about. Fucking A button. Oh yeah? What? Fucking A rights.
Oh, fucking A rights. Fucking beauty, that's beauty. I was singing your praises the other day. Again, it's usually once a week when I talk about, there is no one better at what you do than you, my friend. I don't know if you listen, but we always talk about you on this. No, I listen a lot, and that's nice coming
from all three of you. All three of you are funny and joke around, and I've had fun with all of you. You have such a facility. You're so funny in such an easy way. From the first moment I ever saw you perform, which was swingers, you were just fucking, from that moment on I was like,
this guy is, he's a fucking grand slam, every day is the home run derby for Vince O'Han. I didn't think so, here's why. I was thought, by the way, is the picture locked? The picture is locked, but let's have your notes. Well I was just, I thought maybe you could try a little harder on me. Oh shit.
But Vince, what, what was. I left a little on the field to be honest in that one. What was before swingers? How did you come loaded for Bear in that? I have all of those questions. Was it, I know a little of this, but my brain is not working as well as it used to. So remind me of what I used to know.
I know there's Chicago in there. Well, like you, I started acting very young, but just in community stuff. So like both my parents worked, so I was always performing, I just gravitated to it. You know, probably lack of success in other areas. And for some reason I felt like good attention there. And I have to say, like, as a kid,
this is something I talked to Phillips about. That show that you did that was on, where you were such a smart ass on that show, what was that one called, was it Checkerboard? Yeah, it's your move. It's your move. You were so fucking funny in that. Me and Todd, when we were working with you
on Starsky and Hutch, I brought up, he's like, I loved him on that fucking show. You were such a fucking confident kid who didn't care what people thought about you. But I just kind of liked stuff always as a kid. That stuff made me laugh. Like Sanford and Son, he made me laugh. Absolutely.
You know what I mean? Like Red Fox, he just didn't care and it wasn't like he had a lot of skills, but he wasn't gonna have his day bothered. I don't know, I just kind of found that stuff funny. So I was always performing, started doing improv in high school with Improv Olympic and got an agent in high school and started working and then came out.
But where swingers we, we got benefited from, I think is John and I were hanging out, he came out to Los Angeles and then he sort of took stuff that was going on in our lives and jokes and things that we said and informed the screenplay. And because we were raising money for it, it's almost like Nichols used to do, where he would perform on Broadway before they would shoot something. We were trying to raise money,
so we must have had five, six table readings of that thing. And so we had time to investigate it and think about it and tweak it slightly. And so when we went to go film it and the bars were open and they weren't closed, we weren't bothered because we were so well versed with the material. Oh, that's amazing. Speaking about though, you grew up in Chicago, so did I.
Not far from you in the suburbs, the great suburbs. Yeah, you grew up in Buffalo Grove, I grew up in Glen Ellyn. Yeah, Buffalo Grove and then Lake Forest, and then I went to Lake Forest afterwards. Yeah, Lake Forest is beautiful, by the way. Yeah. But wait a minute, isn't that where we were born,
we're the same age. Same year. So weird. Wait, wait, both in Chicago. Holy, holy shit, Sean, you're right. You and 25 million other people, that's fucking crazy. What are the fucking odds? Hang on, they're pretty good.
What are the odds that two Americans were born in the third largest city in the country and now live in the second largest city in the country? But wait it gets better. Sean's got a follow-up. Everybody hold on. It gets better. So wait did you I read that you did Children's Theatre there? Did you do Children's Theatre? Yeah as a kid I was in I was in community theater where we would play the we would play the the adult roles as as young young. Where did where was that do you remember? That was at the Borton Community Center which is a place,
Robin Williams went to high school when it used to be a high school. Like Bugsy Malone, right? You guys were playing. Yes, without the pies, but exactly. Remember that one with Baio? They dazzled with the pies. It was all okay, because they threw pies.
Remember that one? Arnett, you had to see that one. Yeah, they had a Tommy gun that shot cream puffs, right? Was that McNichol? I think it was Kristen McNichol. Was McNichol? I think it was Christy McNichol. Was McNichol charming in front of the camera with bail? I remember... They were throwing whipped cream at each other and dressed as gangsters.
I was so in love with Christy McNichol when I was a kid. I remember specifically jogging with my dad one morning in the quiet streets of Woodland Hills, and I started crying. I trailed behind him and I just started crying because I had a dream about her and I couldn't believe that it wasn't real. And I just started weeping. It must have been 10 or 11 or 12. So in love with her.
And now I'm going to make her out like her. No, never met her. Not once. I think I met her brother. There's so much about that story is psychotic. There's so much about that. Yeah. That is fucking. There's so much about that. That is, Yeah. Yeah.
Fucking. Red flag alert. I mean, fuck. Wait, but then you moved out, you moved out in 88, is that right? You moved out in 88. Yes, right after high school. I gave up on my academic career.
No college. Oh, so no college. Good for you, me too. Good for you. I was the same way. It takes a lot of guts. It's easy to go to college. It takes a lot of guts to fucking pass it out. Even more bold is not even graduating high school.
You're welcome. Yeah, you're right. Yeah, I only graduated because it was important to my parents, but I was done. I was ready to move on. Yeah, I get that. Wait, what was the goal? Hey, did you go to school for four years?
Did you go to college? Yeah, I went to Illinois State University. Okay. And I have a scholarship fund set up there. Was that still Saluki's? Is that Carbondale? That's Normal Illinois. That's Normal Illinois. Yeah.
Isn't that a funny name? That's the name of the town. I have to say this though, I want to just say this. Because one of the best performances I've ever seen in my life was you in Good Night Oscar. That's very nice. Did you saw that? How great can I tell you how fucking blown away I was. That's very sweet. And this is just me being a kid of the age I am.
The fact that that's not on film makes me want to murder somebody. That was such an incredible performance. That's very sweet Vince, coming from you that means a lot. Anyone that Tony deserved it. Anyone that fucking Tony deserved it. I think he should have gotten, if they could have given out two Tonys, I couldn't believe it. Two Tonys. If you did any one of those things, I was like, oh, he's older, he's got the fucking addictions.
And then the piano playing. It was flawless. At one point in my life, it was very sweet. I didn't have two Tonys. But listen, I... Did they take a Tony away? Did you get Reggie Bush? Did someone take a Tony away? Were you taking money on the side? No, no, one of the Tonys had to go home because his wife called.
So, is that what it is? Wait, but Vince, that's very sweet of you to say, and it means a lot coming from you. No, it's true. Did you guys both see that play? Oh, yeah. Are you kidding? We wept.
We fucking wept. Jason sat in front of him. We wept. We turned and we were like, this is unbelievable. I turned to Will and I said, I think Sean's ruined the podcast now, because now we can't disrespect him.
Yeah. I said, I kept saying, I had no idea he had this in him. I had no idea. You could never tell. From any of his past work, you had no idea. No idea. No idea.
So out of left field. Very sweet. So we were just on a previous episode talking about audition stories. And one of the funniest thing, who was it that was like, was it Jason, it was you that would, no, was it you? That would walk through?
Jason would say that when he'd leave auditions, Jason, what was you that would, no, was it you? That would walk through? No, Jason would say that when he'd leave auditions, Jason, what would you say to them? Oh, but it probably came across as an asshole, but I was trying to be sort of humble and not be as presumptuous that they would ever hire me and I would just, I would say, hey, good luck with this. As I left. Which is just such a wrong thing to say, but I'm trying.
You could take it the other way, where it's like, this is a fucking nightmare and no one's solving this problem. You know what I think they took issue with was the wink that you gave them with that. Yeah. When you gave them a full wink and then a wink. Like a babysitter leaving a house, sleeping with a kid. Good luck with that one. But I read that you did something really, wouldn't you go out and shake everybody's hand afterwards or something? Oh, I was fucking, yeah. Well, I didn a kid. Good luck with that one. But I read, you did something really, wouldn't you go out and shake everybody's hand
afterwards or something? Oh, I was fuckin', yeah, well I didn't know, so I thought it was like a job interview in the Midwest. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So I would be overly kind of nice, and I think it was draining for the people. They just wanted to see you read, and could you do the part,
but I would go out of my way to be like, well it was a pleasure to meet you. They'd be like, who the fuck is this guy? Yeah. Well that's a nice thing? And then I would always say, I was kind of coming from an insecure place, not humble, but I would always, for some reason, compliment the screenplay or the script. I'd say, this is really great.
I mean, even if it was fucking terrible, I'd just say, well, this is great stuff. After you had just finished improvising, probably, right? I don't even know. But I didn't really improvise on those. I was more kind of stuck to the page. And yeah, it's a weird process. The audition process is weird.
Do you remember your last one? Well, the one thing in Swingers is because Favreau made fun of me, I had done a couple after school specials. By the way, I was gonna ask you about that. I saw you in one. Yeah, I did a couple of those. That was my bread and butter. Yeah, wow. I made my bones. I cut my teeth after school
We were tackling shit like sex and steroids and yes, I saw that I was bringing some sunshine to these houses that were filled in darkness Do you remember anything? Do you remember any of the dialogue from any of those that you've never been able to share? Do you or any scene that you've been like fuck? Yeah, one of them was a scene with Billingsley where I discover he's on steroids and I say you're wired all the time You're like some doper He wants him he wanted Nicole Egert I believe to like her and so he was He was pumping up some steroids to do some long-distance running
And you know how they you know how they proved he was on steroids was, because he wasn't necessarily buff at the time, although in excellent shape. But he would just roll up the sleeves on his shirt one time. Once that was a transformation to say the steroids have happened. But I went in for an audition and I started and I didn't get and I was emotional. It was a real story. I came back and Fabro asked me about it and I said uh god I really had a great audition these people were moved I really got to the moment and I was like but I didn't get it because I'm like tall and I'm like three years older than they wanted for the party he's like well why are you even
going in for it I said I don't know they just me in. So that's why he kind of was making fun of me with that story where I make it like I was phenomenal and really a great performance, but I was just too old to get the part and the trailer. No, I've worked with Peter once when I was a kid. He was on Little House on the Prairie. He played a little kid who stuttered named Gideon that I befriended. I think we're both like 11 or 12.
For Tracy, Peter is the star of A Christmas Story. Yeah, yeah, and the director of Couples Retreat. Yep. Yes, and he just did a sequel that he produced and wrote for Christmas Story last year that turned out really well that was on HBO. Oh yes, yes, yes, yes, that was great. Vince, when are we gonna go back to Bora Bora
and do Couples Retreat too? Was that a fun location? Oh God, it was the greatest call I ever got. I think you and Stuber called me and said, hey, we got a part for you in this film. We've named the character Jason. We wrote it for you. Right, we're gonna shoot on Bora Bora
for what, a month and a half. It was the biggest payday I've ever had. It was like the greatest job ever. You were great, you were great, always so funny and it was like our Burt Reynolds phase. What do you mean? Well we just go to a location that's great instead of story. It's a bunch of friends. Cannonball Run, it's like I don't know, it looks like those guys were like let's go. But we just were looking for a place that would be you know know, amazing that no one had heard of and that's what they found.
That's the best. We should do the sequel on a ski mountain. You guys did a couple movies together, right? You did that, you mentioned Starski. Yep. What else? Break Up. Break Up.
I feel like there's another one. I'll think of it. Jason's funny, makes me laugh so hard. Some of the stuff you added just in that scene with Jen and I on the couch, when you're like the counselor in the realtor was so funny. You guys, I would work so hard
because you just go through a rehearsal with Vince and you just see how facile he is and then when they bring in second team to write it, I would run to my trailer and I'd break out a little piece of paper and a pencil and I'd come up with all my alts, all my little things that I'm gonna add and sort of, oh yeah, which is like the biggest mistake,
you know, like you get it all prepared and all loaded and then you go on to set and so now you're trying to shoehorn in some stuff that when I'm practicing my faces in my trailer, it all works great. But then of course, you know, Vince is just like in the moment like you should be and adding great shit and then I'm putting in these lines
that have nothing to do with what about this. Yeah, and so many times I get these looks from Vince like, hey motherfucker, what are you doing? Like you're wrecking it. Just shut up and set me up and move on. Oh Jesus. Oh God, that was a great lesson. I remember you always coming up with fun stuff.
Not nearly enough. And adding stuff. I don't recall it that way. I don't know how you do it. We wouldn't be able to do it with a straight face. I mean, it must be important. Vince, do you remember one time we went to some charity thing we sat next to and the whole time Vince was in my ear commenting on everything that was happening.
And I was like, I'm going to have to leave this fucking place because they think I'm laughing at everybody. Oh yeah. That's your face man? And then the guy gets up who's hosting and he goes, this is your face man? This is the guy you guys decide? And I start fucking crying. Ted Sarandos said he's the guy of honor.
He's looking at me from across the table like, why are you ruining my moment? I'm like, this guy's fucking- Maybe that's why I was invited back. You're fucking killing me. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. You know, I think, were we just talking, were we just talking to Kimmel or somebody about, or was it Fallon when you guest hosted,
was either Kimmel or Fallon and- Letterman. Was it Letterman? Some of them were talking to one, and it was without a doubt like the best week of hosting of any talk show of any year. Vince, would you ever consider that, but just I would just like to see you
on a nightly basis freestyling. Me too. It's enough already with the acting and go on the location. You got a family, Vince. Let's get you a nice studio job where we can enjoy you on a nightly basis. Yeah, we only get to see you cracking jokes a couple times a year.
Like, it'd be like fucking nightly out there just fucking roasting people. Come on, man. You know, it was fun to do the one time, but I think I'd get bored night after night. Wouldn't you guys? Like, this is fun. You guys, this is a super fun show. And you guys have fun. You have each other to joke with.
You get fresh meat every night, Vince. And you can just sit there and just cherry pick and throw bombs. It was Letterman, right Vince? It was like it was it was letter. I had fun doing it It was fun, but but I don't I don't think I would I think I would just get bored Don't you like going on to a new project? Yeah, but you know you take a bunch of months off and you can go do your thing, you know Yeah, do you think you find people do you find Jesus Christ know? Do you, Vince, do you find people, do you find? Jesus Christ, man, are you dying?
I miss him, Will. Do you find people, Vince, like with quote funny people, do you expect people, do you find that people expect it from you right off the bat? Is it something you have to turn on and it's exhausting, but once you turn it on, you're good to go, but you like to turn it off and just chill out and stay silent, like what do you like at on, you're good to go, but you like to turn it off and just chill out and stay silent.
Like, what do you like at home? Do you like to spar with your wife? I think the three of us might be similar where I don't like to be on all the time. Yeah. You know, I don't. I like to joke around and I appreciate a sense of humor, but I'm not out there swinging all day.
I like to kind of slow it down. Like, I like to joke, but I don't like that. But when I first moved here. Sorry, go ahead, Sean, when you first moved here. When I first moved here. Is this close to your dream? Mm-hmm. So you're driving out from normal.
Yeah. No, when I first moved here, I was really, really young, and I think I was just always on because I thought I had to be. Right. And now that I'm older, I'm like, boy, God, did I exhaust a lot of people, I'm sure. What are you gonna come on?
When are you gonna turn on, do you think? When will be the moment? When we're rolling, Sean. You know, Vince, I bet you get the same thing. I was thinking, like, Farrell kinda gets it too, which is when people see him, they're like, oh, this is the fun, funny guy. For Farrell, it's like, oh, you're Hank the Tank.
You're the party guy who's crazy. So I'm going to come at you because you're crazy. And I bet you I wonder if you get that A and B people feel, you know, sometimes you meet people and they they decide they're going to play with you, but they kind of play too hard. They get weird and they say something kind of critical or shitty. And you're like, that's not the game, man. Yeah. But but they try to they try to come at you, so they come at you hard.
You know what I mean? Yeah, I think younger, more so, once in a while, someone thought they were funny for their group. So they would try to do something. And I would really eviscerate them. I would get their friends to fucking turn on them. And I would have a private moment. Their friends would be laughing at them. And I would have a private moment like looking at them like you thought this was
going to go good, like this is your story. You wanted this, here we are. But then I kind of figured it was better, I think as it was better as I got older, you just kind of, you know, try to kill them with kindness, right? You learn that minimal is better. But as I get older, I still get a lot of quotes and yes, people will come up. But now that the comedy's played,
you guys tell me, because isn't it funny, as you get older, people will share with you how they were hurting or a family member was sick and how the comedies was really something they would watch multiple times. So now it's more of an emotional connection than it was when it first hit younger when it was just kind of a funny connection. All the time. All the time. We get this, especially
this because it's such a weird format because people hear us and so they can do shit and whatever. And we started our thing in 2020 and these guys will attest to it. You get a lot of people come up and go, I had a really tough year. I lost my dad and I was at home alone and I couldn't talk to anybody, and you guys, blah, blah, blah. And it's kind of meaningful too. Like it feels, you're like, oh great, like I'm happy about it.
That was me, I told you I lost my dad, yeah. Yeah. Well you didn't lose him. We found him, he just went town over. Yep. He's at a motel. Bender. Big bender.
Big bender. 30 year bender. 30 year bender. Yeah,ender. 30 year bender. 30 year bender. Yeah, Vince, your dramatic work lately is like stunning. My dad just sent me an email the other day saying just how knocked out he was on something he just saw with you doing, that you didn't. Are you loving doing more of that as you get older
and you're thinking about more mature things or whatever? I don't know, I certainly am, but I do miss doing comedies. I miss doing, I miss the studio comedy, you know, that you've done a ton of, I've done a few of, I'd love to do more. Do you miss that a bit? Do you have any knowledge or forecast as to any of that stuff coming back?
Do you have any idea why there's so few of them being made nowadays? Yeah, first off, I think the same as you. My journey's been the same as you. I was fortunate to do like Hacksaw Ridge and then this stuff with Zoller, Brawl and Drag. But now I'm dying to do a comedy again. Like I'm so, it's like Sullivan's Travels, right?
Like, you know, and like Ozarks, I thought, and it was incredible in the fact that you were, you know, directing those and running those on top of it. And you get your plate full, I'm sure, it's great and it's fun, but it does make you miss in agreeance with you, that kind of... Nice studio ensemble comedy where you're working every other day, maybe.
Yeah, yeah, just showing up every time. Yeah, it's true. And then I think as far as it going away, you know, here's what I'll say to you. I just was saying this. I think what happened is we went through a terrible time. Like, if you remember the 80s, they tried it with the lyric censorship of those albums. Like when NWA, I thought, was such a great album,
and then they started putting these warning labels on albums, like parents. And it kind of made the albums blow up. Like, the albums still came out, and it made everyone buy them more. But I think they succeeded a little bit with the studio system to say, now we're going to decide what's funny,
what's not, or what's joking, which is crazy. Cause it's my opinion. Like if you go back to Greek mythology, human nature has always been the same. And, you know, clearly with entertainment, it's, it's a place to explore a song, a story is a place to explore rage or lust or selfishness or anything. It's the outlet.
It's like MMA is the place to explore or football, you know, conflict, not out on the streets, but most people, you know, watching a football game don't take that as a sign that they will get rewarded for tackling someone. So I think there's just a lostness of like how dumb people must be to think like this is a how-to video. It was insane to me. And so I think we went through this reign of terror of being policed of what is and what isn't
versus leaving people their tone. But it never went away, and I mean that, Jason, from this. I think you guys can appreciate this. The stand-up comics when we were doing the big R comics were not that huge, meaning there was a real run in the 80s. They all got their own TV shows. And, you know, people, you'd go on Carson and that was it. You were off to the races.
That was the path. That was the path. But then, like in the 90s, I did this documentary for some guys that I liked that were comics because there just wasn't opportunities. Well, then what happened was the appetite from the audience for funny, odd, adult, dangerous, shocking comedy never went away.
But because the studios weren't making them, you know, Bill Burr, who's great, and other comics like him started selling out Madison Square Garden. They started selling out the Forum. And Netflix started paying $20 million for those specials instead of putting that money behind a story and a movie. So it never really went away. and started song out the forum, and Netflix started paying $20 million for those specials instead of putting that money behind a story and a movie.
So it never really went away. Those guys were always making jokes in areas, like Bill will make fun of having to stand up for veterans, which isn't an obvious path to the waterfall, or men and women relationships. But people laugh and he gets to do it in a way where society appreciates it and no one takes it as a literal thing. So I think like it never went away,
it really helped the standups, but my sense is that it's gonna come back roaring in a big way. Yeah, me too. Because, and I think anything other than that of any kind of questioning of it is just an illustration of like how arrogant someone might be to think they're in charge of like who the fuck is worthwhile.
But what's interesting about that is that all these, it used to be such a great point, that the stand-ups, you'd make it to a certain level, you'd do whatever, you'd do Carson, you'd get a huge deal, and not all of them were great actors or could act in film. Now they don't have to, because they can just do a special a year for $20 million, and getting a movie or a show
is not the ultimate objective for them anymore. They don't need it. Although, if we look back at the great comics, a movie, when it's done well, is always more memorable than the greatest stand-up special. As good as Delirious is. 100%. Right, we all go to 48 hours.
Yeah. Right. Because it's a story that when it works, it's such a powerful thing. So yeah, I think it's, and now some of them are going, like if you look at even what happened with Shane, with Gillis, you know, there was like, he can't, now they're all clamoring for Shane
because he built an audience, you know, was able to reach people directly, you know, and people realize this guy's funny and coming with a point of view and he's trying to make people laugh, right? So he's really had a huge opportunity because he was able to go directly to the audience. That's a model that, you know, I think.
Was this that model in some ways, do you think, this podcast? No, this felt, this was an accident. It was, sorry JB, not to, I think it was, bear with me, with the idea that we started it with nobody, we paid for it for the first year. I mean, we had advertisers, but it took us a little while just because producing the episodes and the equipment
and all that kind of shit. So it was just us, right? I mean, in had advertisers, but it took us a little while just because producing the episodes and the equipment and all that kind of shit. So it was just us, right? I mean, in that way it was. But we never assumed anyone was gonna listen to it and that it wouldn't be around after COVID. We thought it was gonna be three, four months, something like that. Yeah, we really.
Here we are and we get to talk to our favorite people and it takes an hour a week and we just could not feel more- I can't believe it's taking us as long to have Vince on. Can You? I'm taking this as he's talking. It's like unbelievable. How the fuck was he not our first guest?
This is unbelievable. By the way, he is our first guest on our new deal on SiriusXM. Are you serious? No shit! Yes. Let's cut the ribbon. This makes sense that we have Vince as our first guest
on fucking SiriusXM. This is, I was gonna say, we were gonna add it later, but I think that's safe to say. And thank you, Fence, by the way, for wanting and willing to be our first guest. It's a big honor. What a great start.
We just need you to wear a ball cap for six weeks, if you don't mind. It's just as serious, it's just when you're going to the market, whatever, you're picking up the kids, don't fucking sweat it. You can leave it in the car. No, I'll have it as an option, you know. Some days on, some days off, and we'll be there with it.
All right, listen, wait, speaking of all, I love that philosophy, you were talking about all the comedy stuff, and I totally agree. It's interesting. Do you think, like, who was it for you growing up? Who were you like, gosh, if I could do that, or I could be like that, or I could have that career, I could follow his kind of trajectory?
Red Fox. Yeah, I loved Red Fox, it was all of those guys. You know, there was stuff I used to just watch, like, endlessly. And I would just, I always kind of gravitated to the, I think it's a little bit like, well, isn't it like with kids, you hide your eyes and then they laugh because you're getting ahead of them.
It's like horror. The jump scare and the joke, there's something in going where you don't expect it. Yeah, it's all surprise. Yeah, surprise, right? So the stuff that was more, you know, kind of like points of view that was not, Norm was such a fun place in a show or a movie
to see someone with that attitude was fun. That's why Bateman in It's Your Move made me laugh. It kind of reminded me like J. Foxx had that. Right, right, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, he did. But you gotta stay ahead to surprise people and that's what you're, I think, uniquely better than anybody I've ever worked with as far as just staying ahead
and really coming up behind somebody. It's an incredible gift and I love you for it. It's incredible. It's really good. I have a couple things I wanna go through when you were kids growing up in Chicago. Yeah, this is the time to do it. Oh, so just some admin? Just some admin or?
No, yeah, I gotta check these out. We had to tee him up so he knows that you're gonna ask him something. Yeah, here comes a question, Vince. Okay, go ahead. No, wait, so did you know we were born in the same year and we were in Chicago? I'm kidding. Yes, we were. So wait, Buffalo Grove, did you ever we were born in the same year and we were in Chicago? I'm kidding.
This again? Yes we were. So wait, Buffalo Grove, did you ever go to Woodfield Mall, Oakbrook Mall, or Yorktown Mall? I went to Woodfield Mall, Brookfield Mall, and then I went to Northbrook Court. Yeah, because I worked at those malls. And then I used to go to a small one in Vernon Hills,
Hawthorne, Hawthorne was a good one too. Oh yeah, I know, I don't know. All right, so I'm trying to find, okay, so, and then, wait, first of all. Great America was a place that took your dollars. I went all the time. Great America, which is now Six Flags, which is now something else.
Which is now Six Flags. The Demon? The Demon, oh my God, I rode the Demon all the time. Okay, here's a trivia question for you. You put the gum, with the gum on the top? When you went through, people would stick their gum on the top when you walked. They were proving they were there, but it was fast. Yeah, that was fast. Question for you, what was the name on the top? When you went through, there was, people would stick their gum on the top when you walked through. They were proving they were there, but it was fast.
Yeah, that was fast. Question for you, what was the name of the roller coaster before they turned it into the Demon? The Eagle? No, the Eagle was later. That was the fastest wooden roller coaster. And as you would wait for two hours in the Midwest, the thing we would share with each other is say,
this is the biggest wooden roller coaster in the world. That was ours. What was it before the demon? It was, what? I believe it was turn. Oh, yes, I don't remember. What is it? Turn of the century.
Turn of the century. Wow, how do you, how do you make that? I can confirm or deny it, but I believe, it's tough to ask such a trivial question you don't know the answer to, but I'm pretty sure that that's what it was. I can't ride rollercoasters anymore. I'm too old, my equilibrium gets shot,
and I'm immediately nauseous. I can't do it. I'm the same way. I went to Disneyland with the kids, and I was like, I did one ride, and I was like, I'll see you guys later. One ride. Yeah, what happened?
He left. You show up super excited, you're gonna get the kids everything. I'll get all hopped up on sugar. You guys are on your own. I'm gonna be texting over here on a bench. I was texting on the bench, and then I kept going, and then I kept going,
and then I kept going, I kept going like they'd come back and I kept going, you guys wanna take off? Let's get out of here, right? You guys wanna go to the small world or you wanna go home? Those are your options. So we bring the world together? Or we getting out of here?
Oh my God, that's so true. Do you get back to Chicago a lot? I know that you go to Blackhawks games, I've seen you there. Yes. and and but do you do you spend a lot? Do you still feel really tied to Chicago? I do you know, I always say I grew up in Chicago I was I was raised in Chicago, but I grew up in California because I moved here at 18 So I always felt a connection I think everyone from there does and then I always felt such a connection to California because at 18 I moved here and made it my home.
But I do go back in the summer. I always enjoy going there. It's a super fun city. Lots of fun, obviously. I set the break up there because I was from there and I wanted to be in the city. So yeah, in the summertime I'll go back usually. But with the kids, I'm so busy with kid stuff.
Aren't you guys running around like crazy? Yeah, but it's so hot in the summer there. I remember it was boiling when we did that movie there. Why would you go there in the summer? You got a deal there or something? The winter's cold, the winter's a different, the winter's a tougher after cold. In 2010 you skydived over Chicago
as part of the Air and Water Show. And I remember seeing that and I was like, why is he doing that? Yeah, what happened? And to be in full disclosure, the night before I ran into some of the Blackhawks and I had a couple of drinks that evening. Come on.
I was up late. What? I was. And so I got up with a very few hours of sleep. No. But I was committed, I made a date with Skydiving and I didn't break the date. And you just kind of- Wait, you fucking Skydove hungover?
Yes. Yeah. I wouldn't do it. I didn't know what was happening, you just kind of... Wait, you fucking skydived hungover? Yes. I wouldn't do it. I didn't know what was happening. I was just honking to the golden knights. They were very professional. They were military. They were great. And they were telling me all the things. Had you done it before?
I brought my mom. My mom was with me. No, I have never... That was the first time you skydived and you didn't hangover. Yes, and I enjoyed it. It was an interesting thrill, but it's not something I would sign up for all the time. But it was enjoyable. Are you guys... Have you skydived, the three of you?
No, I was about to. I think maybe with the same group. And then I realized a week before, what's the feeling I'm going to have when I hit the ground? It's going to be that I made it. And I don't want to do stuff that I'm excited that I made it. You know, I have children now. I think the three of you to go skydiving would be a nice time. You three should book a date on the calendar, circle it. Right, and we shouldn't do separately, we should just be bound as one.
Take it easy, Sean. Oh, you think? Yeah, we should just make a train, huh? Come on, guys. Yeah, I think I would do it. I think I would do it. Really? You've got four kids.
I know, but you know what? You be safe, you're attached to the people, you do an air train. How does that make it safe? You just both die. I'll do it, I don't have kids, so it's okay if I die, is that what you be safe. You're attached to the people you do an air train How does that make it safe? So I'll both die. I'll do it. I don't have kids. That's okay if I die Yeah, sure you do it. You got that dog. What's that dog's name? Yeah, yeah Scottie oh Ricky sweet Rockies got it Scotty and Rocky What Ricky Ricky? There you go And now a word from our sponsor And now back a word from our sponsor. And now, back to the show.
But now, Vince, you know that I, this is true, I just saw Rudy for the very first time, maybe a year or two ago. Really? Never saw it. And I didn't know, it's one of Scotty's favorite movies. Oh, quick review. Yeah, it was incredible. It was incredible.
And when I saw you, I was like, oh my God, so this is part of the beginning of your whole thing. And then I saw a favorite, I was like, oh, I didn't know John was in, like, I didn't know anything about it. And how soon after that did you and John decide to hook up in Right Swingers? Was it like right after?
Well, he moved out from Chicago after Rudy, and then we became friends on the set, and so we hung out and we moved to Hollywood. And I used to go to all those places, were real places. I used to love to go hear the swing music. All the ex-punk rockers formed these swing bands, and then the Dresden was just a great local bar with all ages.
I loved the Dresden, because you could get like a 75-year-old in there. And it was just like, I liked Marty and Elaine were so fun to go watch. Yes, Marty and Elaine were great. Yeah. So I love that. And then John moved to that area. And so we used to just hang out and go out a lot. And then I think I said to him one day, like kind of what Jason was saying just now, which was, why are we auditioning for these scripts and these things that are so out of touch
and like, what's going on? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because a lot of the scripts were either like tough guy scripts, where like everyone knew everything or they were like, you know, they just weren't fulfilling of the time and so John, I said maybe write something and John came back and had wrote Swingers and I think in like two weeks or three weeks,
he got like a screenwriting book and kind of put it in that form and then we started meeting and talking and going through the script and talk about you know all this stuff but the part that was crazy was that we thought we could get it made you know when you look back at it that's the part that's insane. We were like under our wing we're like okay well we're gonna make this so now let's start the journey. We'd meet like a couple times a week, talk on the phone a lot, okay, who do we think we can get? It was crazy. Yeah, yeah, yeah, but that's how you get shit done.
You believe in it. But you guys can see, because all three of us were born in the same year, I didn't wanna say, because I didn't wanna blow your mind. Now that is a coincidence. No, I was 16. That's a cool year, that 1970. That's in that 1970 no that's in my notes. That's in my nose unbelievable and
And I remember I was living in New York I was a young actor living in New York and when that movie came out for us It was as Gen X rose. I was I was like this is a fucking movie that fucking gets it It's telling the kinds of jokes and the way that I want it to be done It was surprising as JB was saying with the language that was hilarious and unusual and fucking references that were phenomenal. Yes and also made me feel like like being an actor in that moment you were just speaking to me and everybody else. Speaking to me and it wasn't jokes written in a studio system
they didn't feel like it was rewritten by a bunch of different known comedy teams this was new it was different and it was rewritten by a bunch of different known comedy teams. This was new, it was different, and it was real. They were jokes that you could see these guys were real guys. It was like you guys were like rookies of the year and MVP in the same year. It was just like bang. You know what I mean? What was that feeling like? What was the moment on Swingers?
What screening was it or what was the thing where you were like, holy was the moment on Swinger? What screening was it, or what was the thing where you were like, holy fuck, this is really reaching people? The thing that was interesting was that you could imagine the crew we assembled was not, they were just people looking for a job. I think our sound guy specialized in adult films. Sure.
And so we're really committed in taking it. I always wondered about that. Because the sound seemed very erotic. I think the set was a slow day for him every day. But we were taking it serious. And I think the scene, there's the scene where I stand up on the table was improvised, where I stand up
and I start doing the dance and stuff at the restaurant. And the reason I did that was, partially I could just feel like the crew looking at us, like what are these guys, like the whole shoot, like what's going on? And so I kind of made it like, I'm the asshole, I'm the asshole at the restaurant, kind of came from like, I was kind of reacting
to the crew's feeling of like, this guy's out there and people are looking at you in a restaurant like you're going too far, but it was really kind of that. to the cruise feeling of like this guy's out there and people are looking at you in a restaurant like you're going too far. But it was really kind of that. So we loved it, but it wasn't like, you know, on the set, other than the actors, there was a real feeling that this thing was working. And then we did not get into Sundance was the first step. And then but we still loved the movie. And then it got picked up, obviously, by Miramax and released. And then it but we still loved the movie, and then it got picked up obviously by Miramax and released, and then it really just kind of grew over time.
It started to get quoted so much, and ESPN started saying, your money, baby, and then Vegas Baby started being sold as kind of you. So then it just sort of hit this, and I think part of what I think worked about it is there was a vulnerability to these guys. They weren't winning every situation. They're not, everything's not going their guys. They weren't winning every situation. Yes.
They're not, everything's not going their way. They don't have all the tools. And it was really a friendship in that you're helping someone pass a breakup. And I think the vulnerability, and you go out going to meet girls, but a lot of times you'd end up playing EA hockey. Yeah, totally.
And ordering Pink Dye. So I think there was a relatability that wasn't taking itself too seriously. You know what's funny, now that you mention it, there was a sort of a tragic element to it, right? It's kind of a tragedy in a way. It's kind of sad. Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Right? You know what I mean? Like it made the comedy much more profound. It's like an American with Nail and I in that way, that film of just like at the end, you're like, they don't really win. They don't, you know, like it's kind of. Well, you pass in time.
The one thing with the last scene of the movie was, I was flying home to do the movie, to do Swingers. And I was sitting at the airport, waiting, you know, in these rows of seats and I could see the counter. And there was an older gentleman at the counter who kept smiling and waving at me. And I had not done anything, no one knew who I was.
So I was like, why is this guy so confidently like waving at me like real aggressively? So I tried everything. I tried to be like, not, I was distracted. I tried to look at him mean. I tried to, you know, roll my eyes at him, but it did not deter him. He was just overly playful and doing shit with me. I try to look at him mean, I try to roll my eyes at him, but it did not deter him, he was just overly playful and doing shit with me, I was like, what is going on?
And then once he got his ticket, he came walking right towards me, and I thought, this can't be real, no one can be this fucking tunnel vision, this is crazy. And he walked right in front of me, and he had a baby that he was entertaining in the row in front of me. And I was like like this is fucking crazy
I thought this motherfucker was waving and smiling at me I really he's entertaining a fucking toddler So I called John and I said, you know, cuz Trent is is such a great character and confident and fun and all of it but you really focus on the transformation of His character of growing and sort of the great thing that John wrote in the movie is when he kind of is himself and doesn't try hard at the bar and says, yeah, I like quiche, real men. He's like, yeah, I guess my reputation.
When he's not trying to be something he's not is when the door opens, is when the girl connects to him. And so the kind of compliment to that at the end, I thought it was fun if you go, because some of those movies would always wrap up where the character would explain the movie at the end, I thought it was fun if you go, because some of those movies would always wrap up where the character would explain the movie at the end. You know, here's the monologue where I tell you the theme of the movie. And I'm like, why are they doing that?
If the movie did its job, I don't need the character to explain the theme of the movie to me. So kind of as a misdirect, the fun of it was for Favreau to say, you know what, I didn't know, and then all of a sudden it hit me, and you're like, oh God, they're gonna do this in the movie where now the character explains the journey. And then I start thinking the girl is waving at me and smiling at me as a way to sort of pay no attention to the man behind the curtain. Like, you know, Trent is, in the way he sees things,
a good friend and helpful, but John kind of gets quiet and stares off as if to say he's not searching for some pickup stuff, you know, or how to meet someone. He sort of found an inner truth that's kind of transcended him into this next phase of his life. And so I think there's, there's an optimism because you know, he's got past the breakup and there's the openness for love. And we're also kind of moving past, which I think is an important stage, that adolescent stage that we all go through, where you are figuring out how do you make a connection,
how do you say hi to someone, how do you date. There's a moving past that to being more yourself and finding a partner that likes you because you're comfortable with who you are. Yeah, for sure. And fuck, by the way, I love that. Makes me wanna, I'm gonna watch it again tonight. Makes me wanna see it. Oh, Sean. No, don sure. And, and. Fuck man, that's great. By the way, I love that. It makes me wanna, I'm gonna watch it again tonight. Makes me wanna see it. Yeah, me too.
Oh, Sean. No, don't? No, do. I was just gonna, I was about to drop on, Vince, I can't tell you how many times I've said to people earnestly I've ripped, but I just, I go, you, and they were like, fuck, he's about to, I go, you are so money,
you don't even know how money you are. I've said it a million times. Wait, so you, you married married a Canadian just like your mother, but you didn't marry your mother. You married Kyla. Well, we all do. Well, we all do in our own ways, don't we? Oh, shit, Jesus, fuck, let me.
Don't think I haven't woken up with fried chicken on my mind, my brother. Mm. We all go through that cycle, don't we? Uh-huh. So, go through it every day. And I put my house on the market years and years and years ago and decided not to sell, but I heard that you saw it, you checked it out.
Do you remember that? Oh, did I? Yeah. I probably, I might have. Where, without giving away too much, are you? Hancock Park, Hancock Park. Okay, although we gave away a lot, but yes. Yeah.
I love that, I lived in Hancock Park. I lived on Rossmore when I was real. Oh, really? Yeah, I live not too far from there. I love that area. Yeah, that's pretty cool. What's the address, Sean? Wait, I didn't grow up skateboarding, I don't have balance in that way. I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I'm not a surfer, I didn't grow up skateboarding, I don't have balance in that way. I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I'm not a surfer, I didn't grow up skateboarding, I don't have balance in that way.
I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I respect the ocean, it's a powerful entity. I respect the ocean,'m not a surfer. I didn't grow up skateboarding. I don't have balance in that way. I respect the ocean. It's a powerful entity. I like to go in and cool off. Good for you, man. I like to go in and cool off on occasion.
My kids like to go. It's like the amusement park. That's the thing with waiting to have kids until you're older. I'm conscious, like, I don't want to be, you don't want to be an old father. So you force yourself to do the stuff right one would have done when they were younger but sometimes I'm not filled with joy why I'm participating right listen listen Vince I had another kid I had my youngest son I had him when I was 50 but
the good thing is I wear vans so people there they don't know how old I am because they're like this guy's wearing vans he can't be over 30 yeah he must be at least, you know. But I also like the way that you said you respect the ocean is if it's this thing that you're saying it because if you don't say that, it's gonna come get you. So you lay your respects on it. But what about it?
Vince, what about it? What about it scares you? Because what scares about me is like, I've never, I guess all the movies I've seen, did you see Open Water? Do you remember that movie, Open Water? Jostle was a tattoo on my brain. Billy Zane, Open Water?
No? I don't know if Billy, I don't remember who's in it. There's the couple that goes, they go scuba diving and they come up and the whole team is left in the middle of the ocean. Don't you remember that? I'm like, I can't do any of it. I didn't see that.
Now I have a new one to watch. Oh yeah, it's so scary. So what are you doing over there at Manhattan Beach? You like in a volleyball league or anything like that? You know, my daughter plays volleyball. Her team just, she plays for a volleyball club, Mizuno at 13, and they took third in the Junior Olympics. Is that right? No shit.
Yeah, good for her. That's amazing. So she got your height and your leaps? She's a good athlete. Yeah, she's on the tall side. She enjoys that. But yeah, we're just here, you know,, the kids and stuff, they get a lot of freedom to walk around and kind of participate and do stuff.
I like the freedom for the kids. I think it's so nice if they can kind of navigate their own friend day, like the way we did, if the parents aren't so involved. It's easier for us, and I think they get to grow quicker what they like and what they don't like because they're making those choices and this gives a little more freedom to bike around and be able to do that.
But you know what, that's so important, and Vince, I've been thinking about this a lot, all bits aside, we talk about this a lot with like the phones and stuff, right, with the kids. I have a 13-year-old son and a 15-year-old son and the phones are crazy. And I said to them, we've talked a lot about it here, Jason, Sean and I have, and I said to my kids,
look, I'll give you more, there'll be a, if you spend less time on your phone, I'll give you more personal freedom to do shit and go out and hang out with your friends. And I'll back, because I think us as parents, we got so into this thing of like, we got so worried about our kids going and doing shit and yet we'll give them a phone and let them go to the far reaches of the
internet. And it should be the reverse, right? I agree. I so agree with you. If you look at us, all of us born in 1970 and even in our conversation with two of us, some of us not going to college, we were given a lot of bandwidth and we made mistakes, but there was a lot of figuring out just problem solving. Yes.
And so I think if you're too restrictive with the kids, you know, if you do it Little House style, like you and Peter B, then they just, they have a harder time. Like when do they actualize? Is it at like 17, all of a sudden you say, okay, now you're going out there. So I think having conversations,
hopefully they feel comfortable talking to you about stuff. But you're right, if you go to a mall, or you're on the phone, you have a chance to come across stuff that the parents aren't involved in. And it's better for them to figure out that navigating to some degree, with guardrails, obviously. Yeah, right. Yeah, you don't want your kids moving a ton of weight up through South Florida, you know
what I mean? I mean, this is... Even if he promises that we're all going to wet our beaks on it, I'm like, listen, you're not doing it. You know what I mean? Listen, Vince Vaughn, before we let you go, I want to talk about Bad Munch. But first of all, we didn't even get to like Jurassic Park, Psycho, Made, Old School, Dodgeball, Wedding Crash, Breakout, True Detective, Curb.
Oh, Dodgeball, that's another one. Curb. That, you are so funny in that, Bate. Ah, I just read that, it was just an anniversary of that. There was some long article on The Ringer that Ross had sent me that's just awesome to revisit. Yeah, fucking, when you read that out. You stole that fucking, you were so fucking funny
in that movie. That is the commentator. But tell us about Bad Monkey Vince before we let you go. It's with Bill Lawrence, and for Tracy, Bill Lawrence created Scrubs, he created Ted Lasso. Spin City. Ted Lasso. No, he's great.
I used to play in a poker game with him when I was like 19, and he was super funny. And he was a comic at the time. So I knew him, he was a friend and then. Is Bad Monkey a comedy or is it drama? Well it's kind of both. It's a Carl Hiaasen book about a detective in Florida and so the personalities are fun and comedic
but the stakes are real and the kind of crime you take seriously. And so it was just great to get a chance to work with someone who's such a good writer, who, as an actor, you can go and play around, be funny, watch your ideas. Yeah. And, you know, but knows, you know, he knows how to put it together,
and you're not gonna, you know, have to go through that process. So that, Bill's, you know, I think for all of us, when you work on a set and you've done it as long as we have, and this is another thing, as we get older, when we were younger, the crews were so dialed in. You had to be an apprentice to be a prop person for years, right? And so now they're making so much more stuff.
So when you get to go on a set and it's really well run and the guy in charge really is fun and it makes it for a good day. Yeah, that's great. Amen. I can't wait to see it. The bad monkey. Yeah, that's great. Amen. I can't wait to see it. The Bad Monkey is where? Is on what?
That's on Apple. On Apple. On Apple. Gotcha. That's great, and it's August 14th. Can you imagine saying 25 years ago, you're watching, it's on Apple. What?
I know. Yeah, I know, right? What are you talking about, man? What, your show's on Apple? Get the fuck out of here. We don't serve junk. Put some fucking shoes on, you know? Uh, Vince, we've taken up a lot of your Saturdays,
so we appreciate it. Absolutely love you so much. Such a fan of the show and all of you guys. It was a blast to get the chance to come on and talk to you guys. So great to see you all. So great to be with you again, Vince. Vince, you're an all-time champ, man. Honestly, you are an all-time fucking champ. You're the funniest fucking dude.
And thanks for being on our maiden voyage to Syria. Yes. Big deal to us, so thank you. This looks like blue skies and clear waters ahead, so thank you for having me as a passenger. Oh, he referenced the ocean again. Say hi to the family, Vince, please. I will.
Please me as well, Jace. Great to see you guys. Bye, buddy. Thank you, buddy. Bye. The great Vince Vaughn, Double V's. No kidding. Double V's makes a W.
He's so, and such a sweet man. So sweet. So easy. Just so, his comedy is so easy, like seeming easy, what I mean, you know what I mean? Like there's just like an, it's so fluid. But if you guys, you guys haven't worked with them before, have you? No, I wish.
Okay, I'm telling, when you work with that guy, like when they bring in the slate, they say, okay, Rollin', they come in, they hit the slate, ready, and action, and you look at this guy and you know, like it's a Tommy gun coming at you. You know, you usually take sort of comfort and peace knowing that, okay, we're all dealing with
a mutually agreed upon plan here with the script. I know what the next line's gonna be, I know what the next action's gonna be. With him, it's always up in the air in the greatest way, and you just gotta keep your knees bent the whole time. And you wanna enjoy it as an audience member, so you're kinda like half laughing the whole time, but then you can't,
because you gotta stay in character. It's just exhausting in the best, best way. Oh, constantly. Like Tambor level, Jeffrey Tambor level, where you just can't look him square in the eye, otherwise you're gonna laugh. You gotta kinda stare at a cheek, or a nostril or something.
But I did ask him about that question. I asked him about like, you know, cause I've been asked to do like improv. About the malls? Yeah, call him back. Was that the one about the mall he likes? Which malls he likes to go to? No, cause I worked in those malls.
What the fuck's the matter with you? I worked there. This guy is so. So, but I asked about that improv thing because you know, you have to flip, you have to switch on like when you're asked to improvise and it's like sometimes when you're not in the mood, how do you do it?
Like how do you get there? It's just the older I get, I'm like I can't do it. I need somebody. Yeah, but don't you find like, I find like with this, like when one of us is tired or when, I'll speak for myself, when I'm tired, I'm just like, well, I'll just embrace it, I'll just use it, well now I'm just gonna be
even shittier than I usually am. You know, just like, you know, and you just become drier and that becomes your humor for the day. That's very good, I do that too. I do that too, Jason. I think that happens a lot, yeah, I think that we've gotten older, as we've gotten older, certainly that's kind of the thing.
You look great. It's easy to do it here. Will, you look great. No, but just about the, you just show up with what you got today. Yeah, yeah, for sure. And it is what it is. Yeah. And it's not defined, it is deal with it,
but it's not like, hey, fuck you, it's just like, hey man, this is where I'm at right now. I don't have, I can't give what I don't have today. Yeah, and you know what, Jay, and I was worried because I know that you've been really tired, you've been burning it, you've been working your tail off, and then you know what? Here it comes, here it comes.
You were fucking so perfectly fine. Oh yeah. Yeah. I thought we were gonna get a bio to you. No, no, I knew you, no, I'm just kidding, I knew you were tired, but you know, it's just one of those things. And like, you find a way, and then you see Vince,
watching your face light up when you saw Vince. Yeah, I know. It was so fun. I was almost gonna text you, Jay, that it was Vince, and I was like, I love him. It was so fun. I forgot how many times you guys have worked together. By the way, that reminds me of one of the funniest things
Vince ever did. We were doing the junket for Couples Retreat, and he and I were paired together. And the only way we got through the junket for couples retreat and he and I were paired together. And the only way we got through the junket was this game that he played where each time the journalist would come in, he would, we'd take turns giving each other a word that you had to work into your answer. And so like, you know, Constantinople would be like, you know, or, you know, or Velcro or something,
and she would just fucking kill me. Because he's just so straight, so dry. That's funny. And then when you did, did you guys just crack up? Yeah, exactly, and then of course, the poor journalist thinks that we're having a laugh at his or her expense, and they don't know what it is, and it's just dumb actor crap.
Anyway, I'm so glad he came on. It was a long time coming. I was excited for you guys to see what's happening. Nice guest. I mean, really good. Again, it is surprising that we haven't had him on earlier because he's such a fucking heavyweight. I'm fucking serious.
I want a daily dose of him. Wouldn't he be an incredible talk show host? Amazing. Amazing. Amazing. He's made for it. He is. Do you guys get acid reflux ever? Oh, here it comes.
Oh my God. You know what it is? Strap that in. I can't. It's a twinkle in his eye or something. No, I'm just asking if you ever get acid reflux. Yeah, sure, sometimes. No, you know what, Sean?
No, we don't. Let's just move on to another subject. No, I'm gonna, I'm gonna, I'm gonna yes and him, because I just can't wait for this turd. Well, I'm just gonna say, sometimes I get acid reflux, so I have to. Is that right?
Yeah, so sometimes I drink water, you know, to balance the acid-base pH, you know, kind of thing. Sure. And one of those things I drink is bicarbonate, and I was wondering if you guys. I just want to buy it again. I was wondering if you guys have ever had bieeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeee
and I would like to say a nice normal on our very first episode on Sirius to our incredible listening audience thank you for being with us. Thank you for staying with us. Thank you. And have a great day and a very pleasant and sincere. Thank you for stopping. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Goodbye. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Finally handcrafted by Rob Armgerve, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.